good morning Hank it's Tuesday today I'd
like to share some good news with you
because lately I've been feeling a
little bit yeah you know I'm kind of fed
up with 2017 in general and I find large
swaths of the social internet sort of
disheartening and I just feel black but
once a year I'd like to look at some
encouraging global trend lines so here
are five ways that 2017 is actually kind
of the best first charitable giving is
at an all-time high even after adjusting
for inflation at least in the United
States secondly it's possible that 2017
will be the second to last year that any
human ever gets polio the end of polio
will be a huge global health victory won
by millions of donors and heroic
volunteers so far this year there have
been only 16 new cases of wild
poliovirus
that's down from 37 last year for a
little bit of context when I was in high
school there were over a hundred
thousand cases of polio every year third
by some measures 2017 has been the best
year in human history although by many
other measures it hasn't been like if
you measure for instance by Twitter but
like percentage of people living in
absolute poverty lowest it's ever been
percentage of kids in school highest
it's ever been percentage of adults who
can read highest it's ever been cancer
death rates are down not just in rich
countries but globally and also this
baby hippopotamus was born of course
there are ways in which the world is
getting worse in the US for instance
opiate abuse is driving a huge increase
in death by drug overdose South Sudan is
experiencing a famine the world's first
official famine since 2012 and several
other countries are on the brink of
famine horrific ethnic cleansing and
Myanmar has killed many people and
forced hundreds of thousands more from
their homes there are many tragedies
that demand better responses from
governments and individuals but even so
on average the human population is
healthier more prosperous and better
educated than it ever has been okay
fourth babies babies are amazing and
they are being born every day and in
2017 a particular amazing baby named
Oren learned how to crawl also babies
have never been as healthy or as likely
to survive into adulthood as they are in
2017 to understand how dramatically
things are improving let's look at
Liberia so back in 1995 when I graduated
from high school 24% of all babies born
in Liberia died before the age of five
today it's under seven percent now that
is still way too high but it's dropped
by more than two-thirds in just 22 years
now you might be saying oh but
population growth is out of control
except no
everywhere else in the world in Liberia
when health care access improves and
child mortality goes down families
choose to have fewer children here's
what the fertility rate looks like since
1995 so these changes are profound but I
should say that they are neither natural
nor inevitable like this is happening
because of investments we are making as
a species in research in health care
systems and in training and paying
health care workers for most of human
history there was no expectation that
overtime lives would get healthier or
food more abundant because that's not
what happened over time it can be hard
to process just how dramatic these
changes are so for a little bit of
context and the year my mother was born
the child mortality rate in Portugal was
about 9% in 2017 no country on earth
will have a child mortality rate that
high now lots of organizations are
working to keep this progress going but
I want to highlight - Save the Children
which helps kids and families from
refugee camps to remote villages
worldwide and last mile health which
trains and employs community health
workers in Liberia which brings me to my
fifth bit of good news the project for
awesome starts this Friday at noon
Eastern that's when you should upload
your video about a charity you care
about more info and thumbnails available
at projectforawesome.com but the
fundraiser for the project for awesome
begins at midnight tonight and during
this first half of the project for
awesome we're raising money for Save the
Children and last mile health because of
matching donations every dollar you
donate will count as four dollars and
also you can get amazing perks like two
Atari coins and deleted scenes from my
book Turtles all the way down and a
personalized self-care bunny and some of
those perks are limited in quantity so
no pressure em - a little bit of
pressure if it's past midnight you can
find a link to the fundraiser at
projectforawesome.com
or in the doobly-doo below Hank I will
see you in the rest of nerdfighteria at
noon Eastern Time this Friday for the 48
hour project for awesome livestream
dftba